et ce soir nous recevons le philosophe
michael russell son domaine c'est
notamment la philosophie politique
on va essayer de comprendre plein de
choses et notamment pourquoi nous sommes
si défiants vis-à-vis de nos dirigeants
et entre nous même entre citoyens voyons
d'abord les chiffres c'est avec alizée
boissons la crise sanitaire a renforcé
le niveau de défiance des français
manque de transparence ou mauvaises
décisions politiques
selon un récent sondage 66% des français
interrogés estiment que l'exécutif n'a
pas été à la hauteur
en comparaison les européens sont
beaucoup moins sévère avec leurs
gouvernants les britanniques plébiscite
à 63% leur premier ministre boris
johnson dont la politique pour lutter
contre l'épidémie
et pourtant difficilement lisible même
constat en italie où la moitié des
sondés jugent positivement leur
gouvernement la différence s'explique
notamment par la culture politique des
français
les français sont les plus critiques les
plus inquiets les plus revendicative et
les plus inconsidérées comme ce n'est
pas forcément aux entreprises que ce
n'est pas forcément aux citoyens ce
n'est pas forcément aux mêmes aux
acteurs publics locaux de jouer un rôle
mais beaucoup plus une torsion et
exprimé à l'égard du pouvoir politique
nationale un manque de confiance envers
les autorités mais aussi envers la
population
d'après le sondage 61% des français
estiment que leurs concitoyens ont eu un
mauvais comportement durant la crise
du côté de nos voisins européens celle
inverse dans les cités françaises on
retient parfois plus le négatif que
positif
objectivement les français ont très bien
respecté le confinement et l'ont même
mieux respectés que l'on préfère
d'autres peuples pour ceux qui ont été
de manière un peu caricaturale mans
désigné comme étant disciplinés on peut
penser aux allemands et que les français
se sont moins déplacés que les allemands
et que dans un même élan ce qui vous
retenir ça a plutôt être les phénomènes
de déviances que les phénomènes de suivi
seul point commun en europe
l'appréhension du confinement huit
français sur dix ont bien vécu cette
période un chiffre dans la moyenne
européenne
allons plus loin dans l'entretien ce
soir mickaël fait seul bienvenue vous
êtes philosophe professeur à l'école
polytechnique est notamment l'auteur du
temps de la consolation est
après d'après la fin du monde merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation va
revenir sur cette défiance des citoyens
vis-à-vis de leur politique et je le
disais vis-à-vis d'eux-mêmes également
elle n'est pas nouvelle mais elle semble
plus criante
lors de cette crise avec cette crise
comment vous l'apercevez la défiance je
dirais qu'elle a précédé la crise en
tout cas la défiance dans sa dimension
dans sa dimension politique en france
particulièrement parce que on a un
système institutionnel qui privilégie le
pouvoir mais qui se soucie beaucoup
moins de l'autorité j'appellerai ici
autorités si vous voulez le fait qu'un
pouvoir se présenter présente des règles
très normative sur la vie des gens mais
avec une certaine aura une certaine
confiance suscitant une certaine
confiance
or ce qui est par ce qui est
caractéristique de la crise que nous
avons vécue c'est que le pouvoir s'est
imposé dans nos vies on parlait beaucoup
du fait qu'ils avaient plus de politique
que la politique avait perdu un petit
peu de ça de sa puissance à l'ordre du
jour au lendemain et par décision
présidentielle ou gouvernementales
chacun puisse se constater que le
pouvoir politique existait depuis elle
est bien la belle était là et il nous il
se rappeler à nous si je puis dire à
chaque fois que nous franchissions la
porte de notre appartement par le fait
qu'il fallait il fallait une attestation
mais un pouvoir qui était déjà un peu
sans autorité et qui s'affirme comme
pouvoir sacré nécessairement beaucoup de
défiance de la part d'individus qui a
tort ou à raison on a aussi beaucoup
délire et un sur les sur les difficultés
de deux du gouvernement
enfin qui a tort ou à raison considère
qu'après tous de quel droit ce
pouvoir-là spécifiquement sa poserait-il
à moins rester concret que ce soit
particulièrement françaises
c'est particulièrement français on en a
aussi des signes en espagne d'après ce
que je sais c'est une étude approfondie
mais il est certain en tous les cas
qu'il y a peut-être d'ailleurs dans les
pays les plus politiques italie espagne
france c'est à dire ceux qui attendent
beaucoup de l'état il y a nécessairement
aussi de la déception lorsque c'était à
s'avère potentiellement hourihan
défaillant alors il ya la défiance que
confirme et renforce peut-être cette
crise et puis il ya ce que le
journaliste suisse richard wehrli appel
l'hystérie française je vais le site et
dans un entretien qu'il nous a accordé
pendant le confinement sur
publicsenat.fr cette incapacité
collective aussi bien politiques
médiatiques à se dire qu'une crise peut
être
remonté en france il ya trop de
défaitisme on se complaît dans l'examen
de la hauteur de la falaise qu'on ne
pourra pas surmonté qu'en pensez vous
trop défaitisme en france aussi c'est
difficile disons d'avoir une une
position qui soit absolument générale
pour une population de 65 millions
engrangés bien sûr alors je dirais que
certainement le le défaitiste c'est un
peu la rançon du narcissisme
la france est une grande nation je
dirais de l'histoire un pays comme
l'italie la russie qui a beaucoup perdu
de son influence de sa puissance et par
conséquent de sa confiance en elle-même
donc à vous et au peuple français par
exemple pour prendre ce qui est devenu
le jeu d'hier est le fil conducteur de
toute cette crise avoué au peuple
français que le gouvernement n'a pas à
disposition assez de masques c'est
impossible et pourtant ça serait une
forme d'humilité qui aurait peut-être
été à son bénéfice alors on va nommer
stratégie une manière de gérer la
pénurie expliquer enfin je vais pas
refaire l'histoire ici elles étaient
sept mille fois qu'on a besoin d'eux pas
besoin de masse puis qu'on en a besoin
c'est obligatoire ça n'est pas
nécessaire bon autrement dit ya quand
même eu aussi cette idée qui est
partagée alors je dirais pour une fois
qui est un point commun entre les
citoyens français et l'état français
c2c la grandeur si vous voulez de ce
pays ne supporte pas d'être en dessous
on ne supporte pas d'être en dessous ne
supporte pas les réactions sur sanofi le
démontrer c'est de ce point de vue à
juste titre on ne supporte évidemment
pas d'être considéré comme un pays de
seconde zone alors la difficulté
évidemment c'est que la pays la france
est un pays et une puissance moyenne
aujourd'hui
mais que pour autant évidemment elle
doit valoriser ses principes
démocratiques qui ne sont pas
nécessairement seulement ceux de sa
souveraineté défiance défaitisme cette
crise a aussi testé notre capacité à
être solidaires il y en a eu de la
solidarité il y a eu les soignants et
les applaudissements des soignants les
applaudissements aussi des métiers peu
reconnu pas avec les politiques et
parfois pas entre nous il ya aussi eu de
la délation il ya aussi eu du mépris
pour ceux qui ont fait la queue des
heures pour aller chez chez mcdo par
exemple pour ne citer que cela il est
douloureux constat sur notre société
après cette crise où vous êtes de ceux
qui voient au contraire le verre à
moitié plein je dirais que d'abord nous
ne sommes pas encore à la fin donc par
conséquent il faudra aussi faire un
bilan le moment
le moment venu maintenant moi évidemment
je vais pas me prononcer sur les mesures
purement sanitaire qui ont été prises
je constate quand même que l'absence de
confiance que la population d'une
manière générale manifeste à l'égard des
politiques est un peu réversible c'est à
dire qu'en france on a eu un confinement
qui était tout de même l'un des plus
durs et surtout l'un qui est un des
modalités de confinement qui s'est
traduite presque immédiatement par le
renfort de la police
c'est à dire qu'il fallait une
attestation magna non seulement
judiciariser mais de manière aussi plus
politique
on a on a mis la police si je puis dire
dans la dans la boucle ce qui peut être
se justifier du point de vue des effets
attendus mais je trouve que on a eu un
discours aussi souvent qui très souvent
d'ailleurs occupe habits lisant à
l'égard de la population alors qu'au
fond et c'est là où je regarderai plutôt
le verre à moitié plein je suis quand
même surpris du fait que les français se
sont globalement et pour autant qu'on
nous lisent et vu qu'on a fait quand
même beaucoup pétales et les excès de
certains on peut on peut être certain
que les français se sont comportés je
dirais en tout cas de manière civique
dans cette danse est
dans cette affaire qui n'en est pas
moins penser qu'il n'ya pas eu des excès
c'est autre chose mais je pense que les
les applaudissements qu'on a de manière
légitime adressé aux soignants ou à ceux
qui devaient aller travailler
on peut aussi penser aussi à ceux qui
confinés chez eux dans des conditions
qui n'étaient pas c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire pour beaucoup très facile
socialement on peut avoir aussi plus
qu'une pensée d'ailleurs aussi une sorte
d'admiration pour la manière dont tu les
français d'une manière générale mais bon
ce n'est pas ici nationalistes ce que je
dis ne se sont comportés vous diriez
qu'elle a été fragilisée qu'elle est
fragilisé par cette crise notre
démocratie on savait qu'elle était déjà
un petit peu branlante notamment cette
notion de démocratie représentative vous
dirais que là elle elle a pris un
nouveau coup c'est certain je pense que
de ce point de vue l'épidémie et surtout
les mesures prises pour lutter contre
elles n'ont pas tellement variés
d'ailleurs par rapport à ce que nous
avions déjà si je puis dire comme
dispositif juridique c'est l'état
d'urgence qui s'est imposée ici
immédiatement l'idée même de l'état
d'urgence comme après les attentats
alors après il faudra regarder dans le
détail ce qui à l'intérieur de cet état
d'urgence
si vous dites imposé mais quelque part
ça quand même été discutés et débattus
contestées il ya eu quand même un vote
au parlement
oui alors l'état d'urgence sont demande
au parlement de se dessaisir s'est
déroulée réunies pour qu'il le ensuite
ne se réunissent plus jusqu'à ce que
évidemment la question se pose mais il
peut en discuter certains points bien
sûr on peut en discuter les conditions
de la discussion là moi je ne suis pas
parlementaire mais les conditions des
discussions sont certainement rendu
beaucoup plus difficile dans une période
d'épidémie et puis ce n'est ce n'est un
secret pour personne que les
institutions françaises sont fondés sur
le primat de l'exécutif et par
conséquent d'une forme de dépossession
du rôle du parlement et là on peut
comparer avec des pays on a beaucoup
comparé avec le modèle chinois ce qui me
paraît être une comparaison en tout cas
surtout si elle est laudative hasarde
hasardeuse et de laquelle il faut se
méfier on peut comparer avec le modèle
allemand je parle bien des aspects
politiques et pas économie ou là le
parlement est vraiment au centre de la
décision et de ce point de vue là on
recherche évidemment plutôt un consensus
que cette idée au fond un peu paradoxale
selon laquelle on va attendre une espèce
de salut sanitaire de survie quasiment
de la part d'un pouvoir exécutif
alors même que ce pouvoir est déjà très
fragilisés dans les opinions
cette crise nous apprend il nous
confirme beaucoup de choses sur sur le
pays elle nous confirme aussi des
inégalités sociales vous en avez dit un
tout petit mot mais on va approfondir ce
point on l'a pressenti au moment du
confinement mais cette fois il ya des
chiffres ceux de l'observatoire régional
de santé d'île de france par exemple sur
les taux de surmortalité et le constat
est très nette entre le 1er mars et le
10 avril la seine saint louis a
enregistré une augmentation du nombre de
décès de 118 4% par rapport à la même
période de l'an dernier
c'est la plus forte hausse et il se
trouve que c'est le département le plus
pauvre qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
cela montre que ce que là aussi nous
nous savions abstraitement mais qui se
vérifie ici de la manière la plus la
plus cruelle c'est à dire les inégalités
face à la maladie
et face à la mort parce que évidemment
le chiffre de la mortalité globale
explose en particulier dans des régions
socialement détériorer si je puis dire
ou celles qui sont les plus pauvres et
donc ça veut dire que le critère de
l'âge ou des fameuses comorbidités n'est
pas le seul ou plutôt d'ailleurs que ses
co morbidités sont bien souvent liés à
des états sanitaires liés eux mêmes à la
société alors de ce point de vue là
évidemment l'idée qu' il faut de toute
urgence remettre la france au travail à
quelque chose peut-être d'un peu d'un
peu étrange parce qu'elle s'adresse en
priorité à des personnes qui sont déjà
épuisés ainsi elles ne sont pas déjà
malade je veux dire et par conséquent la
leaf est de l'effet de réalité comme
toujours d'ailleurs
c'est le moment où on passe d'une idée
un peu abstraite on parlait ô combien de
l'explosion des inégalités au fait que
ces idées un peu abstraite se réalise
dans le corps et c'est bien ça ce que
fait la maladie à la politique d'une
certaine manière c'est que ce qui
pourrait dire même la mondialisation la
traque du pangolin qui a lu en chine
tout d'un coup elle s'invite dans ma
propre intimité si je puis dire et
parfois pour le pire dans ma propre
maladie est bien là d'une certaine
manière et toutes proportions gardées
c'est c'est la même chose c'est à dire
que ceux qui jusqu'à présent se laissait
dire sous la forme de courbe d'évolution
a beaucoup vu deux courbes aussi de
mortalité est bien en réalité se
manifeste comme étant une des injustices
les plus criantes dans la société
française face à l'espérance de vie et
surtout à l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé elle en a dit un petit peu plus la
directrice de l'observatoire régional de
santé ce sont les pourvoyeurs de
travailleurs clé en parlant de la seine
saint denis
c'est tout ce qu'ils ont assuré le bon
fonctionnement pendant cette période de
confinement ce sont les gens qui
travaillent dans les transports ce sont
les gens qui ramassent les déchets ce
sont tous les gens qui sont en relation
avec le commerce d'alimentation
ce sont les livreurs les postiers les
forces de l'ordre et évidemment les
soignants les français ont tous été
reconnaissants on l'a dit pendant cette
période
vis-à-vis de tous et j'allais dire petit
métier mais non des métiers peu
reconnues jusqu'ici vous croyez un réel
changement de regard puisque c'est ce
que promet un peu le l'exécutif
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron a tenu un
discours sur notamment sur ses métiers
peu reconnues jusqu'ici vous croyez
vraiment qui aura qu'il y aura un
changement de regard
un changement de regard certainement je
crois que le regarde ailleurs sur les
populations défavorisées ou les plus
pauvres le regard social est un regard
et d'ailleurs c'est heureux qui est
plutôt un regard non seulement de
compréhension mais l'affection
maintenant c'est plutôt un changement je
dirais de politique qui est peut-être
attendu le regard changement de regard
ben c'est à dire que si on regarde dans
tous les cas certaines mesures sociales
liées à l'état d'urgence sanitaire je
pense en particulier à la question des
congés à la question de l'augmentation
du temps de travail on ne peut pas
exactement dire que ça aille dans le
sens d'une prise en compte pour
l'instant réelle concrète de ce qui
effectivement se sont battus dans cette
période pour maintenir une société à peu
près
comme virage au niveau de l'existence
minimale est de ce point de vue là je
pense que là on parle beaucoup de primes
devront tout cela évidemment est
bienvenu surtout quand il s'agit de
personnes qui ont des conditions
salariales le très difficile enfin on ne
fera peut-être pas l'économie d'une
revalorisation générale de ces de ces
métiers que dans une certaine image
dirait de la mondialisation heureuse de
la mondialisation je dirais virtuel et
du télétravail qui ressort aussi
renforcé de cette de cette épreuve est
bien dans une certaine image de la
mondialisation heureuse on avait on
était parvenu à parfois à cette idée ou
à ce fantasme qu'on pouvait se passer de
ces métiers qu'on pouvait se passer de
ces personnes ce qui est non seulement
socialement et économiquement le faut
mais ce qui est moralement évidemment
largement discutable il faut s'en méfier
de ces inégalités sociales elle pourrait
donner lieu à de nouvelles colère
sociale et on connaît les colères
sociales en france
bah il faut se méfier d'abord parce
qu'elles sont injustes et puis ensuite
effectivement elles ont des effets
politiques je dirais à de plus en plus
accélérée moi j'ai été très frappé dans
la manière donc là le discours sur
l'épidémie et en particulier sur sa
dimension médicale
ce discours sur ce discours sur les
effets positifs ou négatifs de la
chloroquine la personnalité de didier
raoult se sont greffés immédiatement des
je dirais des oppositions qui sont des
oppositions qu'on aurait appelé
autrefois des oppositions de classes
qu'on appellerait peut-être aujourd'hui
d opposition plutôt de d'idéologie c'est
à dire savoir antique aussi et
géographique marseille contre paris le
représentant médical des gilets jaunes
contre l'élite parisienne de l'inserm
bon alors toutes ces choses là
elles sont à la fois je dirais
inévitable parce qu'à partir du moment
où on était confiné évidemment comment
voulez-vous demander aux gens de ne pas
s'intéresser aux discours médical
si ce discours médical les oblige à ne
pas sortir de chez eux dont certaine
manière c'est inévitable on avait à tous
un avis d'épidémiologie de virologues et
en même temps évidemment elles sont
saison ses passions 1 française et
politique
elles sont je dirais mais pour toujours
pour la même raison elles sont un peu
dangereuse dans la mesure où ce qui a
disparu c'est un peu mon leitmotiv c'est
l'alternative gauche droite c'est à dire
une véritable manière
de politiser le conflit de discuter sur
des alternatives ans manet en matière
sociale en matière économique au profit
d'une alternative extrêmement je dirais
délicate à gérer politiquement et
surtout démocratiquement qui est celle
je dirais delà du petit peuple contre
des élites corrompues bon alors cette
manière je dirais de jouer le peuple
contre les élites
elle sert parfois au pouvoir elle sert
parfois aux opposants du pouvoir mais ne
sert jamais aux démocrates mais quelle
traduction politique pourrait-elle
prendre à je ne sais pas encore parce
que nous avons si je puis dire est ce
que ça peut se transformer en vote pour
les extrêmes lors de prochaines
élections puisque c'est effectivement
une question qui comme nous posez nous
avons en france la chance d'avoir une
extrême droite un jeu là distincts ou
adolescents gauche et une extrême droite
qui n'est pas très à la hauteur si je
puis dire de ses propres enjeux c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas dire que le
rassembleuse rassemblement national et
est politiquement très intelligent dans
cette danse est pleine d'ailleurs elle
n'a pas tiré profit si j'ose dire dans
les sondages n'en a pas tiré profit et
la tête est trop tôt et de manière je
dirais caricatural cela étant au delà
des des parties de la dea des éventuels
candidats
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il va être
difficile pour ceux qui pensent que la
frontière par exemple n'est pas un
absolu pour ceux qui considèrent que le
l'état nation souverain n'est pas
nécessairement le seul la seule forme de
protection pour les citoyens il va être
difficile de l'expliquer maintenant que
si je puis dire on a élevé le gestes
barrières la barricade de soi en mode de
vie par conséquent il va falloir essayer
de peut-être de réfléchir à la manière
de retrouver des formes de commun des
formes de vivre ensemble qui ne soit pas
je dirais en quelque sorte gangréné par
le risque de la contagion parce que le
concept de contagion il a évidemment un
sens médical mais il a des échos
politique d écho politique qui pense
puisque c'est l'autre l'autre corps et a
fortiori l'autre corps étranger celui
qui d'une certaine manière m'apparaît
comme le plus le plus menaçant qui
devient en quelque sorte ce que je dois
tenir à l'écart de moi même alors il est
difficile de dire dans quelle mesure ce
type d' imaginaire très personnel très
intimes se traduira politiquement et
électoralement mais on peut tout de même
craindre
que ce ne soit pas au bénéfice d'une
société ouverte les leçons de cette
crise ce sont aussi des questionnements
autour de la mondialisation et vous
l'avez un petit peu dit on parle
beaucoup de démondialisation de
relocalisation quand commencer vous
c'est bon chemin c'est la bonne
réflexion à avoir
dans tous les cas il ya des aspects
élémentaire si on se rend compte à
l'occasion d'une crise de cette de cette
envergure que la plupart des médicaments
de première nécessité sont fabriqués à
l'étranger que donc on a du mal à les
aléas les relocaliser si je puis dire ou
simplement à les récupérer
bon bah qu'il y ait au moins pour ce qui
concerne les aspects les plus
nécessiteux là d'une politique sanitaire
qu'il y ait une relocalisation ça me
paraît être absolument nécessaire
maintenant si vous voulez c'est comme
c'est comme la frontière on a des
positions qui sont parfois absurdes du
style de celle qui était tenue au début
souvent il part des gens qui comme moi
sont pas des ennemis de la
mondialisation consistant à dire mais
une frontière n'arrête pas un virus pas
si de fait une frontière peut arrêter un
virus puisque le virus passe par le
corps mais alors du coup on passe
immédiatement compte une fois qu'on a
pris la mesure je dirais de la naïveté
de sa première affirmation à
l'affirmation contraire consistant à
dire finalement que c'est la frontière
comme tel qui nous permet de ne sauver
de toute chose
dans tous les cas de figure je crois
qu'on a tout de même intérêt à ne pas
aborder c'est parfois difficile surtout
au milieu d'une crise mais à ne pas
aborder la politique du point de vue du
pirée en particulier du point de vue du
désir de guérir ou du désir de survivre
parce qu'à partir de là évidemment si
l'alternative c'est la survie ou là où
la mort est bien je dirais que
chacun choisira la survie mais parfois
au prix des libertés et puis
reconstruire une indépendance une
souveraineté là aussi ça comporte des
risques et les risques de l'autarcie de
la fermeture de du protectionnisme c'est
très dangereux presque alors la
souveraineté comme tel si vous voulez
tout dépend parce que la souveraineté en
démocratie c'est le peuple donc par
conséquent ici le peuple n'est pas un
concept en fait en tous les cas il n'a
pas été défendu comme cela dans la
tradition philosophique républicaine
n'est pas un concept ethnique par
conséquent entre la souveraineté du
peuple
la souveraineté de la nation et la
souveraineté je dirais du territoire il
ya tout de même des différences amiens à
mon sens il n'y a pas de politique sans
souveraineté en tout cas pas de
démocratie sans une instance qui
s'appelle les citoyens eux qui décide en
dernière analyse est ce qu'on est obligé
pour autant d'en conclure à l'idée que
la souveraineté nationale comme tel est
le seul moyen de nous prémunir d'un
virus alors là je dirais n'y a pas
besoin d'aller chercher très loin il
suffit de regarder les pays
souverainiste en ce sens c'est à dire
qui insiste beaucoup sur leur
indépendance nationale etats unis grande
bretagne pour se rendre compte que la
gestion de crise pour le coup n'a pas
été véritablement
à la hauteur on parle beaucoup du monde
d'après aussi du monde de demain ça fait
même la une du monde qu'on va peut-être
voir le monde des livres interrogé 40
personnalités il leur a demandé de
choisir un ouvrage qui aiderait imaginer
le monde d'après c'est devenu une grande
et belle expression pour se promettre
des lendemains un peu plus un peu plus
heureux un peu plus chantant ça vous
agace d'entendre assez souvent assez
régulièrement cette notion du monde
d'après du monde de demain vous faites
partie de ceux qui se disent oui
effectivement c'est peut-être un moment
clé pour imaginer la suite différemment
c'est à dire bon comme toutes les
formules c'est un peu comme vivre
ensemble où le moment à force d'être
ressasser si vous voulez elles
deviennent un peu un peu dérisoire
maintenant qu'on se pose la question de
savoir de quoi l'avenir sera fait au
moment où le présent est quasiment
insupportable ça me paraît être la
moindre des choses
cela étant je dirais que c'est pas
forcément une période de crise ou de
maladie le meilleur moment pour imaginer
les utopies parce que à force de vie
d'amendé je serais le premier à le faire
sur beaucoup de points en particulier
économiques
à force de reprocher au monde d'avant
tout ce qui a produit la situation de
crise où il a accéléré et bien on
oubliait que c'était tout de même un
monde c'est à dire qu'il y avait avant
oui dans l'avant il ya beaucoup de
choses à critiquer des évidences des
possibilités des libertés qui était déjà
restreintes en un sens mais pas au point
je dirais déjà d'empêcher la possibilité
même du contact ou la possibilité même
de la rencontre donc je ne suis pas du
tout à nostalgie qu du monde d'avant
mais je suis un peu inquiet du monde
après s'il après ça doit vouloir dire au
fond de laisser de côté totalement ce
qui était encore des vestiges de
réel je dirais de l'état de droit au
profit de solutions ou purement
sanitaire ou purement national ou même
d'ailleurs utopie que révolutionnaire
dans la tradition marxiste on appelait
liberté bourgeoise la liberté de se
mouvoir les libertés d'opinion et le
marxisme a souffert de les considérer
comme un peu trop secondaire ces
libertés alors moi je dirais que on
n'est pas obligé de croire que le
capitalisme peut tout résoudre et dieu
sait qu'ils posent de sérieux problèmes
aujourd'hui
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
abandonner les libertés bourgeoise ci
par là on entend simplement le respect
de l'état de droit et de la confiance
que nous pouvons encore manifesté les
uns envers les autres
en dépit de la possibilité que nous
abritons aurions éventuellement un virus
et ce sera le mot de la fin de cet
entretien merci infiniment michael fait
celle d'avoir été notre invité je rappel
des titres de deux de vos ouvrages le
temps de la consommation et après la fin
du monde fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi ion